[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara hallweg guten Abend und
willkommen den Sport in der Sendung hat
gleich Norbert Lehmann einen schönen
guten Abend auch von mir die Polen
bekommen eine neue
Regierung Stunde des polnischen
Parlaments es wählt den proeuropäer Tusk
zum
Ministerpräsidenten und lässt zuvor
Amtsinhaber mor
durchfallen Erleichterung im Saarland
Wirtschaftsminister habck sagt trotz
Haushaltskrise den Stahlhütten
Milliarden zu für den Umbau auf eine
klimafreundlichere
Produktion und mehr Geld für die Clubs
die deutsche fußballiga will sich mit
Hilfe privater Investoren international
besser
vermarkten wir beginnen mit unseren
Nachbarn in Polen denn dort vollzieht
sich gerade ein machtwe el der 8 Wochen
nach der Wahl eigentlich längst
überfällig ist und auf den auch die EU
große Hoffnungen setzt doch die
nationalkonservative Regierungspartei
piss hatte ihn herausgezögert deren
Ministerpräsident moravjetzki hatte die
Parlamentswahlen zwar gewonnen er hat
aber keine Mehrheit im Parlament heute
musste er die Vertrauensfrage stellen
und verlor damit wurde der Weg frei für
den ehemaligen
EU-Ratspräsidenten Tusk und sein
proeuropäisches Partei Bündnis den Tag
bis dahin beschreibt Linda
K das Ende der
peaceregierung der Anfang der neun mit
einer Art Countdown setzt das private
polnische Fernsehen den
Programmschwerpunkt schon Stunden vor
der Abstimmung über seine Zukunft B
versucht bis zuletzt Partner zu finden
doch er scheitert schließlich auch mit
der Vertrauensfrage dass es seit kommt
scheint er kurz zuvor zu
ahnen bedanke mich bei Euch liebe
Landsleute alle die für die peace
abgestimmt haben ich hoffe diese Mission
mit ihren Herausforderungen und Lösungen
fortsetzen zu können in der
Zunft die Zukunft sie gehört ihm Donald
Tusk will noch heute abend
Ministerpräsident werden hat ein breites
Bündnis proeuropäischer Parteien hinter
sich vereint der Koalitionsvertrag steht
Tusk ist bereit zum Regieren doch 8
Jahre peace haben Spuren hinterlassen
nicht wenige fordern eine Abrechnung die
Herausforderungen an Tusk sind groß das
ist ein sehr schweres Erbe und er wird
sich auch sehr schwer
tun die notwendigen
Reformen oder alle notwendigen der
Reformen mit sauberen Mittel
durchzuführen also das große Dilemma vor
dem steht wie stellt man die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit wiederher ohne die
rechtsstaattigen Prinzipien zu verletzen
die Rechtsstaatlichkeit wiederherstellen
das war ein zentrales Wahlversprechen
deros parteien eine Revolution erwartet
zwar niemand doch die Hoffnung vieler
ist groß dass eine neue Regierung unter
Tusk einen Wandel bringt in Polen hat
der Machtwechsel begonnen 8 Wochen nach
der Wahl Linda kirstern in Warschau
jetzt ist es vollbracht gerade wurde
Donald Tusk als Regierungschef gewählt
wie geht's jetzt
weiter also die Machtübergabe hier in
Polen die verläuft wirklich Schritt für
Schritt und seit eben ist es amtlich
Donald Tusk hat 248 Stimmen im Parlament
bekommen das reicht er kann der neue
Ministerpräsident Polens werden und
bedankt sich in diesen Minuten bei allen
die ihn unterstützt haben danach wird ja
aber nicht mehr so viel passieren erst
morgen kann er die Vertrauensfrage im
Parlament stellen und wird sie natürlich
bestehen weil er hat ja schon die
Mehrheit im Parlament und erst am
Mittwoch kann er dann Sam Kabinett
vereidigt werden am 15 Oktober da haben
die Polen gewählt das ist jetzt 8 Wochen
her und die peace hat versucht das
herauszuzögern sie haben alle Mittel
ausgenutzt und ausgereizt die es gab
aber es hat am Ende nichts genützt am
Mittwoch kann tusski die
Regierungsgeschäfte übernehmen und der
Weg ist nun frei für eine neue polnische
Regierung danke schön nach Warschau
Linda
kirstern nach Deutschland hier gibt's in
der Haushaltskrise weiter kein Ergebnis
aber nach außen hin Zuversicht bei den
ampelpartnern angepeilt ist offenbar
eine Grundsatzeinigung bis Mitte der
Woche auch heute abend beraten
Bundeskanzler Scholz Vizekanzler Habig
und Finanzminister Lindner wieder über
Schuldenbremse Sozialleistungen und
Sparmöglichkeiten wenige Stunden zuvor
war Wirtschaftsminister habck noch im
Saarland unterwegs und sagte trotz
Haushaltskrise massive finanzielle
Hilfen für die dortige Stahlindustrie zu
insgesamt geht es um 2,6 Milliarden Euro
Geld für eine grünere Produktion statt
mit viel Kohle und Koks sollen die
Unternehmen etwa mit wasserstoffstahl
herstellen mehr von Susanne Freitag
carteron stah ist
Zukunft ist Stahl ist Zukunft mit diesem
Schlachtruf haben die Stahlarbeiter im
Saarland wochenlang für Förderzusagen
gekämpft Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck kam persönlich zur
Betriebsversammlung mit guten
Nachrichten es ist die größte
Einzelförderung die wir jemals in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik ausgekehrt
haben 2,6 Milliarden habt ihr gewollt
2,6 Milliarden kriegt
ihr
also uns fällt ein Stein vom Herzen wir
sind erleichtert wo Industrie ist da
sind Arbeitsplätze und wo Arbeitsplätze
sind da sind Dörfer Häuser Bäckereien
Friseure die komplette Wirtschaft eines
eines Landes und die hängt an der sechen
stahindustrie die Hochöfen der Dillinger
Hütte wird es so bald nicht mehr geben
70% der Stahlproduktion sollen im
Saarland künftig klimafreundlich
hergestellt werden schon 2027 soll es
losgehen mindestens 3,5 Milliarden Euro
wird das kosten der industrieumbau ist
energieintensiv deshalb gibt es weitere
Forderungen an Berlin den
industriestrompreis brauchen wir auf
jeden Fall auch weil es muss sich ja
auch lohnen für uns hier Stahl zu
produzieren und nicht alles ins Ausland
zu verlagern das stahlprojekt an der
Saar kann erstmal beginnen doch viele
andere hängen immer noch in der
Warteschleife auch der Kohleausstieg
kostet Geld die EU hat gebilligt dass
Deutschland staatliche Hilfen an RWE
zahlt der Energiekonzern bekommt 2,6
Milliarden Euro als Entschädigung dafür
dass er sein seine Braunkohlekraftwerke
vorzeitig stilllegt die Summe sei
notwendig und angemessen sagen die
europäischen
Wettbewerbshüter wer wissen möchte was
die CDU plant falls Sie an die Regierung
kommt heute hat die Partei einen ersten
Entwurf ihres neuen Grundsatzprogramms
vorgestellt auf 70 Seiten fordert sie
unter anderem eine radikale Wende in der
Asylpolitik
Mut zur Leitkultur und die weitere
Nutzung von Atomkraft Karl Hinterleitner
hat
Details es geht ums eigene Profil und
darum wofür die CDU in Zukunft stehen
will der Tag am Konrad adlauerhaus
beginnt überraschend mit
Selbstkritik es ist in der Tat so dass
nach 16 Regierungsjahren es auch eine
inhaltliche Abnutzung gegeben hat und
deshalb ist es ganz wichtig dass wir die
letzten zwei Jahre genutzt haben auch
für
intensive dramatische Debatten das
Ergebnis weniger überraschend Kernpunkte
des Entwurfs sind z.B die Begrenzung der
Migration die Stärkung der Bundeswehr
und die Rückkehr zur Kernkraft vor allem
die Migration stellte Karsten Lindemann
heute in den Mittelpunkt Asylgesuche
müssten zukünftig in Drittstaaten
gestellt werden und gleichzeitig
brauchen wir
kontingentlösung um unserer humanitären
Aufgaben nachzukommen damit wirklich
diejenigen die Schutz bedürfen auch nach
Europa kommen bzw zu uns und nicht so
wie jetzt die illegale Migration weiter
Anfahrt
gewinnt auch ein soziales Pflichtjahr
für junge Erwachsene will die CDU
einführen dieses Stärke die Gesellschaft
als
Ganzes ich möchte hier natürlich auch
auf das Thema gesellschaftlicher
Zusammenhalt in Bezug auf das
verpflichtende Gesellschaft ser
aufmerksam machen weil wir der Meinung
sind dass das dieses
fördert neben dem Zusammenhalt der
Gesellschaft ging es vor allem um die
Geschlossenheit der CDU die sich in
Stellung bringt die CDU Deutschlands ist
wieder regierungsfähig wir sind wieder
regierungsfähig sollte es zu einer
vorgezzogenen Bundestagswahlen kommen
wären wir bereit und das war für die CDU
heute wohl die wichtigste Botschaft das
Programm soll im kommenden meienkraft
treten Rückschlag bei der
Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai kurz vor dem
Ende gibt es Streit über einen neuen
Entwurf für den abschlusstext vorgelegt
vom konferenzpräsidenten aus den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten darin
ist der von vielen Ländern geforderte
Ausstieg aus kohleöl und Gas nicht mehr
enthalten stattdessen ist nur noch von
weniger Verbrauch und Produktion die
Rede Andreas Stamm in Dubai dieser
Entwurf dürfte viele fassungslos
machen das macht er keine Frage vor
allem natürlich die Schützer und
klimaaktivisten dort spricht man von
einem ja Kniefall vor der Öllobby dass
wenn das wirklich unterzeichnet werden
würde man die Begrenzung der globalen
Erwerbung auf 1,5 oder gar auf 2°
eigentlich vergessen könne aber die
bundesaußenministerin Annalena berbock
hat klar gemacht weder die EU noch
Deutschland werden das mittragen oder
unterzeichnen jetzt beginnt ein
Verhandlungsmarathon und er wird sicher
nicht enden so wie es der koppräsident
will morgen nachmittag sondern das
könnte sich sehr lange hinziehen denn
selbst Dinge die klar Schienen wie die
Verdreifachung der erneuerbaren Energie
der strohgewinnung aus Wind und Solar
das steht wieder zur Disposition und
sogar der Kohleausstieg ja selbst da
könnte es sein dass Kohle wieder en wog
kommen könnte wenn man das denn in
einigen Ländern will also man ist hier
eigentlich auf der Zielgraden aber diese
Kop war noch nie weiter entfernt davon
ein Erfolg zu werden Andreas Stamm war
das live aus Dubai vielen Dank
im Gazastreifen attackiert die
israelische Armee weiter Ziele der
Terrororganisation Hamas am stärksten
betroffen ist die Stadt hananjunis im
Süden nach israelischen Angaben waren
wieder Raketen aus Gaza auf israelisches
Gebiet abgefeuert worden die Hamas
drohte erneut ihre Geiseln zu töten
sollte Israel nicht alle
palästinensischen Gefangenen
freilassen der Krieg im Nahen Osten aber
auch weitere Unterstützung für die
Ukraine das sind die beiden großen
Themen der EU Außenminister heute in
Brüssel die ukrainische Regierung hofft
und erwartet in dieser Woche grünes
Licht für
Beitrittsgespräche doch noch leistet vor
allem Ungarn Widerstand und auch beim
Nahostkrieg gibt es unterschiedliche
Haltungen Gunar Krüger berichtet ein
Treffen zwei Krisen ganz oben Israel und
Gaza einige euaußenminister fordern eine
dauerhafte humanitäre Feuerpause doch
nicht alle gehen mit Einigkeit
dagegenüber Sanktionen gegen
gewalttätige israelische Siedler sie
protestierten schon als die USA
einreisesperren erließen nun sagt auch
die EU ihr Landraub gefährde die zwei
staatenlösung dafür ist es wichtig dass
keine weiteren Siedlungen gebaut werden
dass auch die siedlergewalt der von
extremistischen Siedlern gegen
Palästinenser
aufhört zweite Krise die Ukraine in
ihrem Abwehrkampf gegen Russland bittet
sie die EU um einen beitrittsstatus und
um Milliarden für das
Militär beides blockiert Victor Orban
Versuche wie zuletzt vom Franzosen
macron den Ungarn umzustimmen hatten
keinen
Erfolg ich kann aus ungars Haltung nur
so viel rauslesen sie sind gegen Europa
und gegen alles wofür Europa
steht
heute wird der Ärger sichtbar links
Orbans Außenminister rechts der
Außenbeauftragte die EU sperrt Ungarn
weiter Geld wegen Defiziten beim
Rechtsstaat eine Ministerin hofft es
sollte kein Geschacher werden doch geben
und nehmen könnte das Drehbuch heißen
für den EU-Gipfel Ende der
Woche die Folgen von
russlandsangriffskrieg bleiben vor allem
entlang der Frontlinie im Alltag der
Ukraine spürbar Herr permanente Angst
vor Beschuss gibt es auch dort wo
eigentlich Opfern geholfen werden soll
in den Krankenhäusern unser Reporter Tim
Kröger war in einer Klinik in harkiv die
dringend auf weitere Hilfe aus dem
Ausland
hofft auch in den heftigen ersten
Monaten des Krieges hatte dieses
Krankenhaus in hakev nie aufgehört zu
arbeiten dem permanenten Beschuss und
der drohenden russischen Eroberung zum
Trotz viele Menschen verließen die Stadt
aber Krankenschwestern und Ärzte wie
ihur kuszov sind geblieben
obwohl die Belegschaft stark ausgedünnt
war blieb die Arbeit im Krankenhaus für
keine einzige Stunde
stehen bis heute wird HAK regelmäßig
beschossen denn die russische Grenze ist
nur wenige Kilometer entfernt das
Krankenhaus ist wichtig auch über die
Stadt hinaus wir behandeln alle Menschen
aus hakiv aus der Region aus den
besetzten Gebieten und nah
derolgen siehandung in Brüssel
genuk Geld in die Verteidigung stecken
deswegen ist das Land auf internationale
Milliarden Hilfen und Kredite vor allem
aus der EU angewiesen um die Verwaltung
Schulen und Krankenhäuser am Laufen zu
halten ich gehe davon aus dass wir dann
nicht nur geplante Operationen für
unsere Bürger absagen
müssen sondern auch die dringendsten
medizinischen Eingriffe nicht mehr
durchführen
können
hier im Krankenhaus wird Geld auch
dringend gebraucht um im Falle von
Angriffen auf elektrizitäts und
Heizkraftwerke den Betrieb am Laufen zu
halten etwa mit Generatoren vor allem
aber sind die Gehälter wichtig damit
nicht noch mehr Personal
weggeht erst kam der Schnee in rauen
Mengen jetzt herrscht Tauwetter und es
regnet die Hochwassergefahr steigt das
trifft vor allem badenwürttenberg und
Bayern besonders schnell ist der
Pegelstand der großen Filz angestiegen
bei filzbieburg im Landkreis Landshut
gilt derzeit die Warnstufe 3 von vier
dort wurden bereits Straßen überflutet
die Hochwassergefahr in Bayern soll auch
die nächsten Tage
andauern jetzt zu dir Norbert die
deutsche fußballiga hat heute eine
umstrittene Entscheidung getroffen und
eine historische denn erstmals könnte
ein privater Investor in die Liga
Einsteigen von bis zu einer Milliarde
Euro ist da die Rede das die 36 Clubs
der Bundesliga und der zweiten Liga
beschlossen mit einer denkbar knappen
Mehrheit lange hat man hinter
verschlossenen Türen mit dieser
Entscheidung gerungen am Ende aber hat
sich eine wenn auch knappe Mehrheit
dafür entschieden die
Mitgliederversammlung hat heute mit der
notwendigen zwei Drittel an zwei Drittel
Mehrheit für den Antrag zu einer
strategischen Partnerschaft gestimmt
heißt 2 der 36 erst und zweitlig Vereine
sehen die Notwendigkeit die Liga medial
attraktiver zu machen es geht vor allem
um die finanzstarken Märkte in
Übersee wir wollen uns natürlich mit den
anderen liegen messen wollen unseren
zweiten Platz hinter der Premier League
sichern und dazu war die Entscheidung
notwendig die fenlager sehen in ein
Stick kritisch sie befürchten eine
Fremdbestimmung ihrer Vereine die wird
es aber nicht geben das fand ich für uns
auch einen ganz wichtigen Punkt klare
rote Linien gesetzt haben in der Frage
der mit Bestimmung die es so nicht gibt
ein möglicher Investor hat also keinen
Einfluss auf den sportlichen Bereich der
bleibt weit in der Hand der Bundesliga
Clubs die Finalrunde der Fußball nations
League der Frauen ist ausgelost
Deutschland trifft auf Frankreich
Spanien auf die Niederlande ein Sieg im
Halbfinale und das Team von Horst
rubesch wäre sicher für Olympia
qualifiziert zur Handball WM der Frauen
da ist Deutschland bereits fürs
Viertelfinale qualifiziert heute Abend
geht's gegen Dänemark noch um den
Gruppensieg fünf Siege in Serie im
tristen Dezember grau von Dänemark hält
das die Minen der deutschen handalleren
erkennbar auf das Viertelfinale ist
erreicht und damit das Minimalziel
Bundestrainer gaugisch kann nun
wahrscheinlich wieder auf cokapitänin
Alina greisels zurückgreifen im Spiel um
den Gruppensieg gegen Gastgeber
Dänemark Weltklasse Mannschaft auf jeden
Fall sehr breit besetzt im im Kader
haben eine hohe Qualität und trotzdem
haben wir die glaube ich auch und wollen
zeigen dass wir auch gegen
Topmannschaften mithalten können
Dänemark ist der erste echte Prüfstein
um zu sehen ob das deutsche Team die
Qualität für die erste WM-Medaille seit
16 Jahren
besitzt also ich trau den das so ja wir
drücken die Daumen Regen und milde Luft
sorgen vor allem im Süden weiter für
starkes Tauwetter im Allgäu gilt deshalb
eine Unwetterwarnung die Details hat
gleich östen terli Maria taslomka
begrüßt sie im heute journal um :4 Uhr
hier übernimmt morgen Jana pareiges
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend alles
Gute und auf
bald
[Musik]
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen Tauwetter ist angesagt und
das liegt da dran dass deutlich Wärme
Luft zu uns kommt und auch Regen diese
Feuchtigkeit kommt von der biska und
sehen hier der Regen fällt in die weiße
Pracht an den Alpen den Schnee der
zuletzt reichlich gefallen ist ja und es
gibt Tauwetter dieses Wasser fließt in
die Flüsse und Bäche und sorgt für
Überflutung und hohe Pegelstände schauen
wir in die Nacht und da regnet es im
Süden und auch in der Mitte gibt's Regen
ansonst nach nordenin auch einzelne
Auflockerungen bei tiefsten Temperaturen
von 2° im Südosten und 9° am oberrein
Morgen dann noch mehr Regen mit einer
Warmfront die hier aufzieht und eben für
dieses anhaltende Tauwetter dann sorgt
im Westen da bilden sich einzelne
Gewitter dieser regenkomplex wandert
dann nach Nordosten weiter bis zum Abend
die Temperaturen dazu 4° ganz im Norden
und 14° im Südwesten die nächsten Tage
am Mittwoch noch kräftiger Regen 2 bis
11° maximal Donnerstag wird's Kühler
Regen lässt allmählig nach und dazu ist
dann auch Schnee dabei Freitag 0 bis 7°
und deutlich sonniger schönen
Abend